though you may not have heard of Cameron
Boyce before his tragic passing at the
age of 20 you almost certainly saw his
face perhaps even earlier than you
remember while many may recall that
Cameron Boyce was biracial they may not
realize his grandmother played an
important part in American integration
history the 1954 Supreme Court ruling
Brown versus Board of Education
established that the segregation of
public schools was unconstitutional
under the 14th Amendment ending the
precedent set by py versus Ferguson in
1896 as part of public school
integration 12 black children now known
as the Clinton 12 began attending
Clinton High School in Clinton Tennessee
this Monumental change in 1956 created
the state's first integrated public
school and boy's paternal grandmother
Joanne Boyce was one of those students
in 2016 Cameron and his grandmother
recounted the event for Disney Channel's
Be Inspired short series for Black
History Month speaking to people about
the event Joanne recalled all of us all
of our parents every single student that
walked down the hill with me all of our
parents wanted us to do better they
wanted us to have better opportunities
so therefore education was number one
for them Cameron was evidently proud of
the work his grandmother and her peers
did especially since the Public's
reaction to the integration was largely
retaliatory they looked like they just
wanted to grab us and throw us out they
didn't want us at all I could just see
their hate in their heart the young
actor told people things are going to
happen in your life and you're going to
face adversity but if you grow from that
and learn from that you're a better
person because of it how could you not
be amazed by their bravery she has
chosen to forgive not forget and she's
learned from it and has just grown from
her experiences Cameron wanton a Daytime
Emmy Ward for outstanding promotional
announcement for the segment while many
know Cameron Boyce for his acting he
started as a professional dancer for
seven years he focused almost
exclusively on Dance Before
transitioning into acting while talking
to Young Hollywood in 2018 about the art
form voice noted it actually did come
pretty naturally to me I sort of came
out of the womb dancing in a 2019
interview with glass magazine he even
called Dance his first love a sentiment
Voice's Father Victor echoed in a June
2022 Instagram post memorializing his
son trained in ballet break dancing
hip-hop Jazz modern and tap boys kept
dancing at the Forefront of his career
in life projects like The Descendants
Trilogy continued to let him Flex the
skills even after he pivoted toward
acting in a 2018 interview with hero he
explained it's really cool to have that
in my back pocket in case I need it
there are so many roles that require
dancing or singing and you have to be
able to do all three in addition to
using his Dance Training for acting
roles he and four childhood friends
formed the dance crew xmob voice
expressed to Hero that he considered
xmob some of his oldest and closest
friends and the group continued on even
after Boyce's passing to celebrate their
time with Boyce xmob posted a long form
video to their YouTube channel featuring
clips of the actor dancing and Home
Videos a group had taken together in
2008 panic at the disco music video
served as Bo's first acting job in the
band's video for the song the green
Gentleman things have changed he
portrays the child version of Ryan Ross
the band's guitarist at the time Boyce
is the first character on screen playing
with a set of Russian dolls as the
band's lead singer Brendan Yuri's voice
comes out of one of the toys and behind
the scenes look at the video uploaded to
YouTube by fueled By Ramen audiences can
see a young voice talking about being in
a music video for the first time and the
costume he wears to match Ryan Ross the
Wardrobe is really funny I wouldn't wear
this this was the first of several music
videos Boyce would appear in other than
his own work within the descendants
franchise Boyce also turned up in the
video for hardwired by Haley Knox as the
male lead and is credited as one of the
lead dancers and choreographers and the
video for hosier's almost sweet music
after the panic at the disco music video
Bo's first Silver Screen appearance was
in a spin-off of the classic medical
soap opera General Hospital in 2008 he
took on the recurring role of Michael
Stone Kates Jr in the short-lived
General Hospital night shift the
character was the 5-year-old son of
Jagger Kates one of the main characters
in the second season over the course of
seven episodes audiences can watch the
young actor fine-tune his acting skills
as his character goes on a journey of
receiving an Autism diagnosis while a
small role it started what would become
a fruitful career on TV for boys from
there the young actor guest starred in
the popular Disney Channel series iies
Good Luck Charlie and shake it up before
landing leading TV roles on the network
the small screen wasn't the only place
audiences could see boys before winning
his role in the Adam Sandler Le
grown-ups vo's first big screen effort
director Alex oza's 2008 supernatural
horror film mirror saw him in the role
of Michael Carson the film's premise
involves sinister Reflections killing
their real counterparts Midway through
the movie Michael's reflection begins to
act odd causing his parents to be
concerned and paint over all the mirrors
however this doesn't work for long as
Boyce's character was later found
scraping the paint off the mirrors in a
trans-like state before the movie ends
Michael's reflection nearly drowns him
but his mother comes to the rescue in
2019 shortly after Cameron's death
Boyce's father shared an Instagram post
that included the mirrors poster which
depicts the young Boyce sitting
cross-legged on the floor seemingly
staring at his reflection in a puddle of
water Victor Boyce's simple Instagram
caption read Cameron's first movie he
never watched it the Disney Channel
series Jesse was Cameron Boyce's Big
Break on the network giving him his
first leading role in a TV series he
played luk L Ross a boy who loves video
games and has a particular fixation with
his Nanny the titular Jesse hello I'm
Luke and you
are way too old for you the series was
fairly successful for Disney making it
to a Four Season and airing 98 episodes
however the show might not have happened
at all without an important conversation
between its lead Debbie Ryan and a
producer according to an interview with
the Star Telegram as Ryan's previous
Disney series The Sweet Life on Deck
neared its conclusion Ryan and executive
producer Pamela eels oconnell looked at
other series for Ryan to star in okell
had previously worked on The Nanny and
the concept for Jesse came up as the two
bounce pitches off each other without
that conversation Jesse may not have
come to be and without the series
Boyce's first major role may have come
at a very different point in his life
the shift into a leading role in a TV
series impacted many aspects of Boyce's
life in an interview with the emy's
website the actor said that he started
being homeschooled due to the filming
schedule and that he even began taking
college courses to learn more about
responsibility and accountability in his
career he recalled all the the things
you're supposed to learn after you
graduate from college I had to learn at
the ages of 11 12 and 13 so at this
point in my life I feel that because I
was in that professional work
environment my whole outlook and life
changed he acknowledged staying in a
more Traditional School setting may have
changed who he was as a person since he
wouldn't have had the same
responsibilities he did while starring
in Jesse despite everything changing
around him Cameron Boyce worked to stay
grounded and not fall victim to the
complicated fates of many Disney actors
who came before him in his interview for
the emy's website he explained for the
people who view an actor's life is all
glamour and we just want to be famous
it's a job that we do just like any crew
member who has a job we like to do it
not to be in the Limelight it drives me
crazy when actors lose sight of Reality
Part of not losing sight of reality was
keeping his personal and professional
Pursuits apart he explained that once
shooting rap for a day instead of
spending the evening reflecting on his
performance he'd go outside and play
basketball speaking with glass magazine
Boyce also reflected that despite his
busy schedule he still tried to find
time to feed his love for dancing
whenever he could while doing an
interview with Shon magazine Boyce
discussed that his parents were the
wants to instill in him a weariness
about his path as a child star this
caution helped Boyce avoid the chaotic
and often harmful situations many other
young actors face Bo's death came as a
shock on July 6th 2019 just under a
month before the release of the third
Descendants movie the young actor was
found unresponsive in his home which he
shared with two of his former castmates
his family made a statement in the days
that followed saying Cameron's tragic
passing was due to a seizure as a result
of an ongoing medical condition and that
condition was epilepsy until the
statement made by his family it was not
widely known that the actor suffered
from the disease an autopsy conducted by
the Los Angeles County Department of
medical examiner coroner initially
deferred the cause and manner of Boyce's
passing however after additional testing
it was confirmed that the actor suffered
a sudden Unexpected death and epilepsy
also known as suep in the wake of
Boyce's untimely passing the red carpet
premiere for the third Descendants movie
which was scheduled to come out just
Weeks Later was cancelled a few days
before the event Disney confirmed to The
Hollywood Reporter that instead of
hosting the premiere they were were
making a donation on boy's behalf to The
Thirst project the company also stated
that after securing boy's family's
permission that the broadcast of
descendants three would be dedicated to
Boyce Boyce's final feature film run
screened in February 2020 at the mammoth
film festival in the film Boyce stars as
a teen named Cal who struggles
emotionally after several difficult
events in his life Bo's performance was
praised by critics with Jordan Elizabeth
writing for Common Sense Media the star
commands the screen with authenticity
and depth slowly transforming as Cal
becomes a shell of his former self with
each violent act and what would you even
have done
borgi shoot them with the gun that you
stole from your mom the boy appeared in
an episode of the CBS Series code black
in 2016 his post Disney career didn't
really start until after his death his
first major series after Jesse and
Gamers guide to pretty much everything
was a kathern Han L HBO series Mrs
Fletcher which debuted in October 2019
Boyce played Zack the college roommate
to the lead character son Brendan and
speaking to Oat living about his
experience filming the series Boyce
discussed how shooting in New York City
helped Inspire him saying New York is by
far the most stimulating City I've been
to I came back home rejuvenated and more
inspired to make AR Voice's final
performance came out in March of 2021
with the release of Paradise City on
Prime video created and written by Ash
aalson the series is a continuation of
the writer's 2017 movie American Satan
starring alongside fellow Disney Alum
Bella Thorne and boooo Stewart voice
portrayed Simon an aspiring Young
musician the series was renewed for a
second season and Albertson told
Entertainment Weekly that he had many
season of the show planned before the
First episodes were even filmed sadly
this would require the showrunners to
recast the voice though few concrete
updates on the development of the next
season have been announced as a fall
2023 Cameron Boyce famously worked
alongside Adam Sandler in grown-ups and
grown-ups 2o Boyce played Sandler's
onscreen son and the two became fast
friends as part of Adam Sandler's movie
deal with Netflix the comedic actor made
the horror comedy huie Halloween the
movie follows huie played by Sandler as
he watches over Halloween festivities in
the town of Salem Massachusetts the film
was meant to Mark Sandler's reunion with
his former co-star as Boyce was
originally cast as one of hu's teen
co-workers however Boyce's death
resulted in the part being recast only a
few days before the movie was set to
begin filming in his place Boyce's
friend roommate and Jesse co-star Karen
barar was cast in the role the film
included a tribute to Boyce during the
credits as an image of Sandler and Boyce
appeared on screen a heartfelt caption
materialized beneath which read gone way
too soon and one of the kindest coolest
funniest and most talented kids we knew
you live on forever in our hearts and
are truly missed every day like many
actors Boyce was a philanthropist and
worked with many organizations in his
time in the spotlight he raised
awareness for causes such as helping
impoverished communities gain access to
clean water and trying to end violence
on college campuses Nationwide starting
in 2014 Boyce was actively involved with
United Way of America's Home walk which
works to end homelessness he raised
money for the organization through
various campaigns including offering
personal shoutouts to others raising
money and he participated in the opening
Ceremonies for the 12th annual home walk
in Los Angeles in May 2019 alongside
fellow actor John
weros every year this makes a big
difference and so I'm really proud to be
here the homewalk that year raised over
$1.1 million and saw more than 100,000
people participate in the 5 km walk
voice also teamed up with it's on us an
organization that aspires to end sexual
violence on college campuses the actors
spoke on behalf of the organization at
the 2019 Biden courage Awards which was
hosted by the Biden foundation and it's
on us the ceremony recognized
individuals working toward the
organization's Mission through
intervention organizing and policy
change through his work with its on us
Boyce even met was soon to be President
Biden at the time of his death Boyce was
working with Delany tar co-founder of
March for our lives on a social media
campaign contributing to the effort
against gun violence called wielding
peace the campaign featured images of
public figures civilians and victims of
gun violence holding household objects
and art supplies as if they were guns in
a letter shared by a representative
Boyce explained this concept and wrote
wrote that the goal of the campaign was
to inspire people to seek alternative
Outlets such as art or fashion through
which to express themselves rather than
turning to a deadly weapon the initial
photographs which were later published
by the Cameron Boyce Foundation featured
Boyce and his roommates Karen barar and
Sophie Reynolds the campaign continued
on with descendants co-star Dove Cameron
participating in a wielding peace
campaign to remember Boyce on his 21st
birthday in 2020 in conjunction with the
Cameron voice Foundation a merchandise
collection featuring the tattoo Cameron
got in honor of the initial campaign
helped raise money for both the
foundation and the actors fund Co relief
one of the organizations Bo regularly
worked with was The Thirst project which
works to bring clean water to
underdeveloped countries in 2017 the
young actor used his platform on
Instagram to help raise $27,000 in 40
days Boyce continued to work with the
thst project until his death being
honored by the organization in 2018 with
the pioneering Spirit award after
raising more than $30,000 to help build
two wells in a swany speaking with
billboard thst Project's CEO and founder
Seth Maxwell explained it was more than
an honor for the money he raised for our
work it was really an honor for a person
who knew no bounds in giving of his time
and energy after Boyce's death Adam
Sandler hosted a Facebook fundraiser for
the organization which helped raise over
$155,000 to build additional Wells later
in 2019 during the 10th Annual thirst
Gala The Thirst project renamed the
award Boyce received as the Cameron
Boyce pioneering Spirit award in honor
of the actor's memory and his lasting
work with the organization that year his
roommates presented the award to Craig
Thompson a YouTuber who who raised more
than $150,000 to help build wells in an
effort to celebrate Cameron Boyce's
memory and philanthropic work the
Cameron Boyce Foundation was started in
2019 the Cameron boy Foundation honors
Cameron's Legacy by aiming to cure
epilepsy the Cameron boy Foundation
helps fund research and spread
information with its now what campaign
the campaign's goal is to help newly
diagnosed individuals make more informed
decisions about their epilepsy and
provide a toolkit that can help patients
decide what comes next for them both in
their lives and regarding their health
based on on its 2022 impact report the
foundation boasts that more than 800
members are now part of the now what
support group in addition to working to
increase awareness and research for
epilepsy the Cameron Boyce Foundation
also celebrates and supports the other
causes Boyce worked for in life after
the 10th Annual thirst Gala the
foundation donated $88,000 to build a
well in Uganda the organization credited
the donations from their supporters for
making the significant donation possible
and pledged to continue The Thirst
project in Voice's name much like the
wielding piece photos information about
The Thirst project remains on the
foundation's website under the page
camps causes the board of directors
includes Boyce's parents Libby and
Victor and Boyce's former castmates pton
list and Debbie Ryan former castmates
Dove Cameron Sophie Carson boooo Stewart
Adam Sandler Ken barrar Sophie Reynolds
and descendants director Kenny Ortega
are part of The foundation's Advisory
Board the Cameron Boyce Foundation
started an annual Gala the cam for a
cause a fundraiser for the Cameron voice
Foundation to end epilepsy in 2022 the
Galla raises money that the foundation
uses to help fund epil Epsy research
those who knew Boyce and other invited
parties attend the event and speak to
the foundation's goal share their
memories of the late actor and support
epilepsy research in 2023 the gala
included the awarding of the inaugural
Youth Empowerment award a distinction
given to a young individual who is
making a difference in the world the
award is being used as a way to honor
Boyce's Legacy in the work he did in his
life Yara shahii the first recipient is
known for her appearance as Tinkerbell
in Disney's recent Peter Pan and Wendy
movie and starred in the series blackish
And granish discussing how Shahi earned
the award The Hollywood Reporter wrote
jiti will be celebrated for her activism
surrounding stem awareness women's
rights civil rights and her countless
acts of kindness towards others
according to the
foundation